hi I'm ray I've always loved eating
dessert making dessert
I've known as a little snob on the
Instagram today I'm making a giant cat
shape cream puff cream puffs tomato it's
a choux pastry which is light and
delicate my cream puffs will be filled
with a sweet pastry cream and berries
these days are is a hard exterior
three-center and a splash of tartness
it's perfect for the guests today for
it's my friend Nikki hello Nikki is a
battlefield producer who also appears on
a tasty show eating your feed it's me
okay hey do you like my thread I love
your sweater I chose it for you it's
very nice I've never seen you wear it
before I bought this ten years ago and I
only won once
so this dessert is me as a dessert yeah
we've a friend for two years now yeah I
know you like berries you have a cat do
you have a cat you also have a cat like
personality in my opinion okay it takes
a little time to become really good
friend with you okay but once you'd like
that person you will never leave that
person so Nikki yeah first I'm going to
make custard delicious so I'm going to
add a cup of milk and I want to use real
vanilla bean taste much better really is
like a notable difference
it's a notable difference you're going
to split vanilla in half and scrape
vanilla beans inside of the pot I don't
know I just love good vanilla combined
with milk and bring it to almost boil
meanwhile I'm going to separate egg its
pastry cream used in any other desserts
I feel like I've only really had it in
like an eclair cream sauce earlier in
Japan we have like bread filled three
it's pastry cream really good sweet
bread yeah this is really nice the sugar
no yolk and mix until it becomes pale
white color I just wanted to show off my
sweater but I'm gonna wear April now oh
the little eyes peep out the top I like
that is it creepy
no it's very cat-like
okay did you ever have cats growing up
yeah I always had a cat gone enough why
don't you have one now I'm a suit cat so
when I was living with my parents house
I always sneeze or like my mother always
worried and when I start living myself I
stopped it was the cat I'm adding
cornstarch and flour
that makes pastry clean with thicker
milk is boiling so I'm going to add
first a little bit because egg yolk and
if you pour everything it's gonna
scramble eggs and also through the
machine so it catches vanilla beans pod
I feel like desserts fall into two main
categories chocolatey more like fluffy
and fruity yeah
and I've always been the fluffy and
fruity train I feel like I'm louisia
yeah I like chocolate but I if I have to
choose one thing I like custard I like
cream cream cakes winking so I'm
combining everything and bring back to
pot and I'm going to hook us Toronto
it's thickened oh you're gonna cook it
again okay there it's a leftover vanilla
pod you can wash it oh and also you can
put a new sugar pot and it makes really
good vanilla sugar oh that's great
yeah I wish I you just throw away
expensive they are yeah now I'm going to
heat it up and hook onto its victims
okay I feel like the few times I've
tried to make pastry cream this is where
I lose it oh man it never comes together
yeah so the good thing to know
yes rubber spatula instead of a whisk
it has more surface so you don't burn
the mistake people makes it's either
burned or become lumpy mmm
cooking custard once it starts seeing
the bubble you are going to cook another
two or three minutes and it's done
be sure creams like one of those like
staple things in like culinary school
right oh yeah he was one of always on
Peggy Sam's like cooking eggs am i yeah
and also Nikki you want it to be a chef
when you're young right
yeah going to the Culinary Institute of
America would be a really cool thing
yeah isn't it kind of funny that you
came around and I ended up doing things
anyways yeah
so is it done now is it yeah it's them
it's very my taste it yeah thank you
[Music]
myself
well that's delicious yay so custard
it's done I'm going to put plastic wrap
but you have to press it down so the
skin doesn't form on the surface when
it's cool down and I'm going to put in
the refrigerator
couette for like 30 minutes okay see you
later I'm going to make sure pastry YUM
have you made that before my family
likes to make cream puffs together at
the holidays oh that's night and then we
we don't make pastry cream because it's
Nutella and whipped cream so I'm adding
water and butter and pinch of salt you
are going to boil butter and water and
add flour you have to evaporate all the
water so when you add egg in the door
absorb all the egg that makes puff
pastry puff
yeah that's interesting I don't know I
pretty sure that's what that great so
far [ __ ] do you can pipe this your
pastry dough into hot oil and fry it
oh it's become true oh yeah you should
master this doll you can make bunch of
different design you're gonna melt all
the butter to bring it to a boil turn
off the heat and add the flour at once
all at once
mm-hmm you wanna shift the flour so it
doesn't get lumpy and you're just like
mix a little bit mix very
uncharacteristic and a kind of fun way
into a ball yeah oh wow really fast and
even you turn off the heat so you have
to take off the heat in order not to
burn on the bottom well it's kind of
foaming to the ball and it look like
shiny are you gonna wait until though
it's cool to touch because you wanna add
egg next you don't want to scramble egg
it's a very delicate dough I feel like
it's not too delicate to compare
macarons microns to me seemed very like
snooty and high-caliber mm-hmm I'm
perfect
small expensive I mean who would you
think is a macaron them myself yeah
probably so don't call to touch I'm
going to a supposed to be three eggs but
it comes in different shape and sides
I'm gonna just have to see the texture
again
knowing you're cracking egg clock on the
splicer face so shelter don't get a mark
also have to add egg one bite one it's
lonely mm-hmm
there's no sugar in this dough no that's
because we are distilling yeah are you a
cat person or a dog person bowl me too I
don't you do you know cats don't now to
each other because it's not a way that
they communicate each other it's a way
they communicate with humans near it
yeah and also like a palliative I heard
the doctor make a squeaky noise yeah
that's the sound of like someone emailed
I know that the dough looks good so I'm
going to put in a piping bag I'm going
to draw a shape on the parchment paper
mmm
so cute small tape for piping this one
it's fine cuts the dough is very thick
but when you're piping something really
runny like whipped cream or custard you
twist here and put it inside and Bend
there so it doesn't come running out
yeah I know this guy you didn't know
yeah I watched your macaron video that's
coming out let's fight dough on four
corners so the paper doesn't fly away so
I'm going to pipe it into cash shape
because it holds really good shape so
whatever you pipe air it will stay
almost like it it's become a little bit
puffy and I'm gonna do twice and then
ear yeah cute yeah yeah I'm brushing
some water so choux pastry puffed up in
the oven it doesn't have to do with
steam yeah exactly
how long is gonna bake for 375 for 20
minutes lower the heat to 350 for 15
minutes okay so you want to bake high
here first so it puffed up and lower
heat to make sure everything cooks after
you turn off the oven leaving the oven
for 10 minutes
temperature suddenly changed puff pastry
my deflate so that's why you want to
leave in open okay right so this has
been chilling in the refrigerator it's
hurts I'm going to make it soft again
don't put your ass not in that you're
gonna eat it oh yeah so it's Suzie
Latinas this is good custard oh yes kind
of cleanly peeling off from the ball
that means the flour you clean is fully
cooked so this is the sign wow it's
pretty satisfied I like but some a
little bit alcohol in your dessert but I
know that you don't yeah so I'm not
gonna do that
what would you do I who died Randy just
a little bit so it kind of have a nice
about the food it's like it came off
really funny but I'm just translating
Japanese wine right right okay in
Japanese a total Nanaji
means like okay I'm gonna just down add
heavy cream a little bit to loosening up
I'd say okay if it's too jiggly custard
nice and smooth and I'm going to whip
heavy cream some people use I feel like
most people maybe use a Honda mixer
you're not going to I'm kind of use huh
very rustic so rustic also want that
take a long time it takes a longer time
but you can control the thickness you
want to go but you just put in there I'm
its powdered sugar instead of using
granulated sugar I add powdered sugar
because it is all well know I can't
believe your hand
so when I wasn't working at the
restaurant every day at 5:00 p.m. I have
to whip cream maybe like 10 cups for
throughout the service and I had a to do
behind why they wouldn't let you do it
with a mixer the savings like I never
seen how to mix in a professional
kitchen but they ever play seeds I being
I've never seen hand mixer so I usually
go to walk-in refrigerator and whip it
because you will find in the
refrigerator if you over mix it it's
become butter all right it's become like
very like super grainy yeah nice so I'm
gonna stop right here so I have
strawberries blackberries blueberries
and your favorite Roz I love berries and
cream have you seen that berries and
cream starburst commercial no sometimes
we have very dear friend Ola gooseberry
gooseberries mm-hmm so it's kind of like
a sweet tomato to me does it have
anything to do with the animal the goose
yeah goose keep up on the link kind of
tastes like sweeter tomato biting into
it is like biting into a cherry tomato
yeah but it's not a tomato he tastes I
don't know okay you like it I'm not
going you know well about it it looks
like a snitch from Harry Potter and that
Harry is like oh I'm gonna go check over
here
so I'm going to cut in half and fill
with cream this is gonna be a little bit
tricky
yes I'm gonna okay stop talk I'll stop
talking
did you just gasp wow I'm going to feel
cream okay thank you do you feel like
you like making desserts because they're
more beautiful I like making dessert
because like gift to that person are you
are not making this art for yourself to
do that I want to make it really pretty
there is time very time I want to put
everything in balance for sweet
strawberry then raspberry this is so
pretty
oh it's okay yeah yay so final touch I'm
going to sprinkle sugar coats rice ball
it's watch out
[Music]
clicks all done they see it's my desire
for you what do you think I love it I
think you really nailed it
it's like when you watch tasty videos
and all you want to do is eat the thing
I get to eat the thing yeah and I always
love eating this obvious tea or coffee I
love that so I'm going to make Keith
thank you up thank you out now they're
too small no beautiful yes I feel like a
moss thank you so much you're welcome I
hope you like it how do you eat cream
sandwich oh yeah mmm good
mmm your choux pastry is so fluffy and
delicious but it's also just like really
tasty hmm and both creams huh right yeah
it makes a difference
yeah custard and heavy cream and the
berries I love everything about this
good thank you miss me as a dessert hey
I feel it thank you for watching I hope
you enjoyed learning about cream puffs
and my friend Nikki until next time
cheers Cheers
[Music]
it's not ramen don't flora yes